ahora vamos directo a Buenos Aires con
nuestro corresponsal natalio cosoy Y es
que Argentina sigue registrando una
inflación superior al 100% anual en
marzo
a natalio los saludo primero Pues a
Argentina es un país que ya está
acostumbrado a vivir con alta inflación
pero hoy la situación es extrema porque
sigue sin tocar techo lleva dos meses
por encima del 100% Qué efectos está
teniendo esto sobre los ciudadanos
o se registró en marzo Qué tal Buenas
noches un 7,7% de inflación desde abril
de 2002 no había estos niveles de
inflación en un solo mes en los efectos
son muy duros para la población por un
lado por supuesto no alcanzan los
ingresos excepto en algunos casos en
aquellos que tienen la capacidad de
empatar a la inflación por supuesto
podrían ser por ejemplo comerciantes que
pueden actualizar rápidamente precios
asalariados en el caso de aquellos que
tienen real poder de negociación sobre
todos los que pertenecen al sindicatos
fuertes quedan un poco retrasados con
respecto a la inflación pero llegan un
poco mejor pero hay una masa enorme de
asalariados que no están en fuertes
sindicatos o directamente en la economía
informal que quedan afuera de esa
capacidad de recuperando poder de compra
y eso es demoledor para sus ingresos por
otro lado hay una especie de
desconcierto General Respecto a los
precios no está claro Cuáles son los
precios correctos de las cosas es muy
difícil cuando uno va a comprar un
servicio o un producto saber si está
pagando lo correcto y por supuesto es
muy difícil planificar compras a mediano
y largo plazo es una situación de
grandes orientación la los expertos
asignan diferentes causas a esta
inflación por supuesto la emisión
monetaria pero también la propia
dinámica inflacionaria que lleva los
actores de la economía a aumentar
prevenir preventivamente precios también
lo que se llama la inercia inflacionaria
algunos señalan también muchos el gasto
del estado y la necesidad del estado de
financiarse con emisión monetaria y los
expertos dicen que lo que hace falta es
un gran plan de estabilización muy
fuerte pero las condiciones políticas y
sociales de Argentina hoy no son las
ideales para eso se necesita un gran
acuerdo y estamos en un año de
elecciones con resultados inciertos en
el que es muy difícil un acuerdo
político a nivel nacional grande que
pueda llevar adelante un plan de
estabilización
natalio pero que dice el gobierno porque
el Banco Central ya da por sentado que
los precios van a seguir altos al menos
por lo que queda de este año
el gobierno ASUME que la situación
inflacionaria va a seguir existiendo
pero el secretario de política económica
Gabriel ruinstein Si bien reconoció que
era una cifra alta dice que es de algún
modo circunstancial por efecto de la
gran sequía que vivió Argentina también
de un brote de gripe aviar Que afectó
sobre todo los precios de los alimentos
y él dice que tiene la expectativa de
que en abril se reduzca un poco de hecho
también la portavoz de la presidencia de
agabrera cherrutti señaló los efectos de
la guerra en Ucrania sobre los precios
internacionales y también mencionó la
sequía también una mención desde el
gobierno respecto al aumento de precios
en algunos comercios de cercanías Que no
respetan según el gobierno Los acuerdos
de precios que hay sobre todo en
alimentos en productos de primera
necesidad que sí dice se respetan
grandes cadenas de supermercados
bueno Y también por otro lado el dólar
en el mercado informal ya pasó la
Barrera de los 400 pesos Qué relación
hay con este fenómeno inflacionario que
estamos viendo ahora
Bueno es muy difícil para los argentinos
ahora hacerse de dólares de otra manera
los accesos al Dólar formal que vale
muchísimo menos casi la mitad
son difíciles también hay una forma de
comprar dólares de forma legal a través
del mercado financiero eso no es para
todo el mundo el dólar ha sido
históricamente una reserva de valor para
los argentinos especialmente en un
contexto inflacionario entonces también
es un indicador de la búsqueda de cuidar
el valor del dinero para los argentinos
y además también a pesar de que es como
decíamos ilegal por fuera del mercado
legal el dólar blue como se llama en
Argentina no deja de ser una suerte
indicador de referencia para los
argentinos de los precios en general y
también seguramente sobre que
confirmarlo con expertos pero
seguramente tiene algún pequeño efecto
sobre los precios